[Musique]
vous deviez qu'est ce que vous faites là
et pour qui roger sap mmai voyait bien
c'est pour mon arrière arrière petit
fils eh bien voyez quand on veut causer
un peu pour travailler
schaper humain j'avais beaucoup
d'arrière petits ensembles qu'ils en
pensent quoi qu'on en dise mais des
arrières arrières ont éclos
un rôle que toi vous vous demandez quel
âge vous avez en othe cultive parce
qu'on est trop ville bientôt 88
moi j'ai envie ça s'approche mais la
plus grande partie de votre vie vous
devrez passer ou à peu partout
aujourd'hui comme l'hybride
oui mes parents sont juniac aux lignes
on a passé dans le jura on est venu dans
la bresse puis nous voilà peut-être
parce qu'à proximité d'où chine et
peut-être mon terrain que je suis je ne
sais pas l avis étaient différentes de
maintenant oui il était un peu plus dur
que maintenant c'était bien plus du
temps mais on n'avait pas tous car on
veut maintenant ce n'est pas pareil
qu'est ce qui vous manque le plus mais
c'est elle et un thaï comment t'y es
quoi c'est quoi c'était l'argent et qui
tirent elles plus qu'est ce que vous
voulez gagner pas beaucoup on m'avait
l'un des buts et qu'anthony avec 65
euros par mois c'étaient les anciens
feront bien entendu et puis on ne
retenait quatre ans pour la retraite par
mois
ça faisait pas beaucoup pour vivre avec
déjà deux ensemble ça se provoque ou par
mois
et vous vous avez travaillé oui moi je
travaillais avec la culture avec deux
vaches je pouvais en élevant des enfants
comme ça je parle bien travailler
autrement je me suis placé est en jeu il
n'accepte où vous êtes marié à quel âge
19 ans et comment avez vous rencontré
rencontrer votre mari nous étions placés
ensemble dans la même ferme
vous avez été à l'école quel âge mois ou
para jusqu'à 12 12 ans mais on n'allait
pas l'été jamais on n'allait rien qu'un
petit peu l'hiver n'ont pas beaucoup de
travail à l'école vous savez vous avez
appris quoi lire à écrire et puis jean
petit peu mais je faisais beaucoup de
pattes de mouche vous croyez qu'on a
promis aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'on s'occupe bien mille des
ententes school et mes parents ne
voulaient pas me dire tu vas me réciter
des leçons il savait ni lire ni écrire
et déjà déjà vous vous en seriez plus un
peu plus oui moi je me suis tu jouais
déjà heureuse en faisant beaucoup de
fautes de l'arrivée on ne pouvait
cependant avec ma famille mes parents
s'ils avaient besoin d'une led et a
obligé d'aller là faire faire chez un
voisin tant connu
mon frère aîné n'a failli tigres
autrefois on prétendait que je suis est
là et pas tellement de 25 sourire
qu'elle avait besoin d'apprendre des
deux bonnes ménagères c'était
l'essentiel
mais maintenant il y en a encore
beaucoup qui aiment mieux aller
travailler parce qu'elles ont - peine
que de s'occuper de leurs enfants
est-ce que vous pensez que vous étiez
finalement
plus heureuse au moins heureuse que vos
arrières arrières petits vous
arrière-petits-enfants oh ils sont bien
que je n'aie pas été jamais oui la vie
les gens qui sont bien tous plus heureux
maintenant que qu'on est des pantins fou
et puis comme j'ai entendu dire à mes
parents ce à avant c'est encore pire
ils mangent elles du pain mais y avait
pas beaucoup de blé d'arrivée il matin
faisait des gauches avec la farine de
maïs pour faire des jeunes et les jeunes
avec sa maman j'ai pas mon copain y
avait pas pas ils peuvent être entendus
dire à mon père calais c'était comme de
mon temps il y avait le premier
domestique lé deuxième troisième
quatrième et ben il est cité dans une
endroit que le premier domestique que
nous ça soyez même pas pour manger sa
soupe il met à jour table manger sa
soupe l'accepter manche saint qui
partait commence à partir au travail
après c'est encore plus dur que son
appareil et et ils n'ont encore ça
convient plus dur
comment passez-vous une journée
maintenant je voulais vous dire à boire
et à manger à tricoter bien tout ce
qu'on peut faire c'est tout ce qu'on
peut faire quand on est temps qu'on
n'est pas important et bien en quoi
pensez-vous avoir été utile à vous à vos
enfants ou petits enfants 12 arrière
petits enfants
on n'a pas pu l'arrêter bien utile parce
qu'on n'a pas pu leur donner grand chose
j'en avais pas seulement pour vous
est-ce qu'il y en ait pas pu leur être
bien utile on les a élevés mais c'est
tout c'est tout donner du pain c'est
tout et si votre arrière arrière petite
fille était un peu plus grande
quel serait le principal conseil que
vous donneriez si vous aviez un conseil
à lui donner
avec votre expérience on peut pardonner
de conseils aux jeunes ils apprendront
bien mieux à l'école qu'on n'était pas
de la prendre
[Musique]